everyone welcome to this short clip of
simulation you know me I'm Alan sake and
I'm currently with my brother Lee
Christie what's up man hey what's up
YouTube yeah thanks for joining us we
would greatly appreciate it
Lee actually came in for a meeting today
thanks to our boy Jordan who introduced
us and you just brought this item into
our studio and I was like hmm what is
this and so Lee is an inventor and he
has invented something very interesting
that we're gonna show you guys right now
and so let's go ahead and give it a demo
this is Ori its clandestine transit
and as you see that boom just like that
it's tough because it's tough because
that was not on purpose I swear you got
a stress test it and also your you guys
stress tested also the fingers can pinch
it's important to be careful for now
there are going to be iterations on this
overtime
it's an early prototype will have some
iterations overtime let's let's let's
see that one more time in action so so
just like this clandestine transit so
he's just walk-in around and boom just
like that that's awesome a brother
awesome alright let's switch back over
to the other cam so so what do you what
do you expect to continue innovating on
with this board when maybe could we see
an ory claim best time yeah right now
it's pretty pretty unique the the
original prototype got stolen actually I
made it at the MIT Media Lab in a course
called how to make almost anything
shoutout to dr. Neil Gershenfeld yeah
and yeah the original got taken to the
White House action these were a bomb I
got to check it out oh it's so sweet and
then that one got stolen and then one of
my my best the top mechanical engineers
misty West sky and Aaron's a sick
mechanical engineer he basically like
made this next version of it and
designed this next version and it's a
particularly liked well thought out
version of it and so I'm just kind of
seeing it's really kind of fun to watch
something improve like it's getting
better and better and better but we
haven't like really user tested yet so
we're at that point now where we're
looking for people that you know want to
pay a lot of money for something that no
one else has and they can be our you
know our beta testers so we're kind of
at that phase where we're just kind of
figuring out what people want so if
anybody sees this they're interested you
know reach out find find misty West and
ask for ask to try an organ so after
trying Ori also will hopefully see this
go through some more R&D and development
and we'll see it maybe even hit the
market soon in a version that's you
clandestine transitory it's very
interesting stuff and you got a bunch of
other projects that you're working on
unpack more soon yeah it leaves a very
interesting man so we'll talk more we'll
unpack more soon thanks everybody tuning
in to the show everybody vote on the
board clandestine transit all right
peace guys peace
[Laughter]